life could be so nice in Miami Beach
R&B a mizar's new home in exile but when
the Venezuelan refugee fled to the
United States he had to leave behind
everyone he loved after six months
behind bars as a political prisoner he
feared for his freedom his safety and
his future
I felt persecuted every day the police
published a list of wanted people and my
name was on that list published in
several papers it was a dangerous
situation but the only thing I did wrong
was demanding Liberty his new home lies
in a neighborhood of stately mansions
fancy on the outside but so rundown on
the inside he's embarrassed to show it
he is safe here he says a job in a hotel
earns him money to survive and to help
his mother in Venezuela there is nothing
to eat many people either undernourished
or even becoming fat because the only
things that you can buy our pasta and
flour that's it southern Florida is home
to 100,000 Venezuelans bringing with
them the tensions of two opposing sites
protests are coming here against the
business partners of Venezuela's
president Maduro self-declared
president's Guido's supporters say they
are trying to keep their money safe by
investing in real estate in the
neighborhood
Jose Kalina represents the politically
persecuted Venezuelans abroad he shows
us around the Miami suburb of Doral
which many Maduro supporters now call
home we try to find these people and
suggest they are expelled from the US
and have their assets confiscated it
doesn't make sense that those who fled
persecution have to live next to the
perpetrators this Venezuelan restaurant
is the preferred meeting place for white
duel supporters
for R&B Amis are an active member of
Quan whatõs party the self-declared
president represents the country's
biggest chance for freedom in decades
I believe we are now witnessing the end
of the Maduro regime we just have to
carry on and he will lose popularity and
power which is already happening day by
day in the area maybe it's this optimism
that keeps our own be armies are alive
and his hope that one day he can return
to his home safely